A friend watched a video where you talked about a smoothie with carrots, celery, and apple in it. Do you have a recipe or a suggested ingredients for that smoothie?
No, I don't. So we have a lot of people that will be juicing. And typically this is the most common juicing protocol for cancer.
This was really a big part of Max Gerson's juicing protocol for cancer, which is carrot, celery, and apple.
And then making a smoothie out of it. Personally, I don't like smoothies. I like to drink it. My drink not have to, you know, not have it be thicker or you have to cut it chew it down.
So I like to leave things juiced. So there's times that I'm juiced carrots, apples, and celery, sometimes put other things in it, whatever vegetables that I had.
But in it, really, whatever you have. So we have people that are juicing all sorts of different things. And then if you, it depends on how you define a smoothie, then some people are putting it's a protein powder in it, then some people are putting their greens in it. They're, they're, they're a pedestal, they're other things that the powders that they're on, they're adding to that, I guess you're calling that a smoothie. So I've called that a smoothie.
That's my wife calls it a smoothie. She puts some yogurt in it and different things like that. So it's just how you want to make it. If you are just blending and not juicing.
I do believe that you have a really strong blender like a Vitamix or even a very good new triple length of some kind. You can, you know, blend the carrots apple and celery.
I think it would have hard time with some of the least I think the carrots and celery would be difficult for a blender to get through.
But I do think with a Vitamix, you could blend it up and make a smoothie out of it. Really, we talked about the smoothie. You're just adding other things to a juice.